now we just got an amazing sizzle reel
with a couple teases for we're gonna be
seeing in season two but you left us
with one heck of a cliffhanger when our
man showed up and we learned that the
Justice Society of America exists in the
flare overs
now how is the JSA going to figure into
season two what can you tell us
producers Phil well the JSA you know
even heroes have heroes and for us the
JSA is you know it's like that Golden
Age generation of superheroes and for
our team you know it's kind of like a
bunch of you know modern people meeting
that Greatest Generation it's it's a
it's a story of you know if ours is a
family it's it's like getting to meet
your grandfather's and maybe
grandmothers and realizing that they
were they were real superheroes which is
not to take anything away from our guys
but you know we think Phil well you know
we have an unconventional way of doing
things on our team and it's uh you know
for some of you it's something to look
up look up to like for Brandon for you
Dom it's people who just annoy you now
that's a really good tease for the JSA
but we want to know who are gonna meet
will you tell us which Justice Society
members we're going to be seeing in
season two okay fine um doctor midnite
Stargirl I said with her obsidian a lot
of what I was most afraid of is
happening I'm forgetting what up
commander steel not to be confused with
citizen steel oh and have I left anyone
else huh well well I guess there's
someone at the table if you've already a
legend in my mind and vixen now speaking
a victim and vixen in citizen steel we
have two new faces on this panel with us
today welcome Nick and Maisy hey we're
very excited to get to know you in
season two and actually Maisy you just
met the rest of your cast yesterday
right anyone started filming yet Nick
only has three days under his belt but
but for both of you and for our
producers what can you tease of what
these two new characters are going to
bring to the legends dynamic oh man I
just don't want to mess anything up um
it's funny um I spent three days working
so far and I had a moment with Victor
because I always wanted to work with
Victor really yep and I'm home where was
I was doing a scene with him was looking
at him and and I there were silence
after he started talking and I'm staring
at him and he looked at me and said you
returned and we picked it up but uh more
than anything I'm just excited to work
with everybody when we get into the
trenches and you know not spoil any more
secrets for one day here at comic-con my
first question I had today at comic-con
I've never done this before but I'm
sitting behind mark and somebody asked
me a question and I answered it and this
was what I saw from mark that's not true
that's a lie this is like
we were sitting next to each other he
did that amazing what are you excited
about in joining this team this season
well I think it's just nice to have some
new energy in the team and just to shake
things up a little bit and I guess we
analyze what it means to be a superhero
both ways the Justice Society of America
and our guys really sort of challenge
that and push each other to really go
and save the world I guess and I don't
know if we've officially said this
before but we're going to say there
today this is your season two lineup of
legends of tomorrow so let's give them a
big round of applause
you